hi everybody i'm jonathan trance and i
got a particularly deviously hard
challenge for you guys today so when you
see the puzzle on your screen go ahead
pause your videos and let's see if you
can solve this really tough one this
game comes to us from Alexi go Knopf in
badr Java from the Aero flat open 2016
and in this position black played the
move rook takes f2 and he's hoping
perhaps that if you take back I can take
your rook on e6 and everything is fine
however white has a very dangerous and
powerful move that black must have
missed in this position so go ahead and
pause your videos and a big congrats to
anyone who's able to find this one I
think it's a really tough one
I think a tempting move in this position
is the move rook h6 which obviously
threatens a lot of things especially
where takes h7 however you have a very
crafty defense here as black in this
position you can play rook on f5 the
idea is to threaten Bishop to c5 so if
for example you get out of the way of
the pin a sample continuation might go
Bishop c5 will take on f5 take on e3 it
will end up trading the Queen's
and clearly white is four choice here
but it's in no way as clear as the game
continuation so heading back one more
time if that was the move that you
thought it was go ahead pause your video
again see if you can solve it here comes
the solution white played the move rook
to g6 a fantastic move introducing
threats on g7 and the game now is
totally over so in the game he tried
Queen h3 but with the King and the
discovery like this
everything's pinned he can't possibly
last for very long and in this position
he resigned thanks everybody for
watching go ahead let me know in the
comments below were you able to get this
one I know it's particularly tricky this
time go ahead give this video a huge
thumbs up and I'll see you next time for
another tactical challenge